everybody wants to make a smoothie now
here's the problem with smoothies there
are two kinds of fiber there's soluble
fiber and there's insoluble fiber
soluble fibers like pectins like what
holds jelly together in soluble fibers
like cellulose the stringy stuff and
celery real food has both fruit has both
when you consume the fruit containing
its inherent fiber called an orange or a
pear or even a grape the soluble and
insoluble fiber it forms a gel a whitish
gel on the inside of your intestine
formulates a secondary barrier which
prevents absorption early on in the
intestine the food moves through the
intestine faster reaches down below and
that's where the bacteria are and so the
bacteria will chew it up instead of you
so when you're consuming fruit you're
really feeding your bacteria and that's
good for your liver but when you put the
fruit into a blender a Vitamix a
nutribullet a Breville or any of the
other machines that are now on the
market what's happening is you are
shearing the insoluble fiber the long
stringy stuff to smithereens so you
can't formulate that gel on the inside
of your intestine you will still get the
benefits of the soluble fiber and that
means that the food will still move
through the intestine faster which means
you'll get your satiety signals sooner
which is still somewhat valuable but of
the four things that fiber does to help
your health you will have lost three of
them so I think it makes more sense to
eat the fruit
[Music]